right the moment in the first half for
shard higgins
exerting maximum effort to try
to put the ball into the end zone now
it's a different issue altogether that
he took an illegal hit
from daniel soren all right wait wait
let's just start right there how are we
ever supposed to make that tackle then
are we just going to give up now and
just let people dive in the end zone
we see we see guys do it though yeah is
his head's still going to hit his head's
in front of his shoulders his head's
still going to hit his head's going to
hit every time there's no way you can
dive
and talk you know what boulder and
there's no way so then we have to stop
him
don't get don't get beat then don't get
beat he wasn't that was he was probably
having to go into a submarine
yeah but he had to go in submarine first
that should have been called though
under a rule that gets it's like it's
like it should never be called it's the
dumbest rule ever they call that i will
quit watching football if they start
calling that number yeah i will they
called it they called it in the second
game did you quit watching buccaneer
saints when they called somebody was
diving in the end zone and that happened
no no but lowering the head long they
had to make contact with the helmet it
was a very very bad call it gave the
saints half the distance to the goal
early in the game as they were trying to
score a touchdown there was a grazing of
the helmet right then you have to lower
the helmet and initiate contact it was
lowering the helmet it was like a
grazing at the side it never should have
been called the guy to get lower the
helmet has got to go lower i mean it's
we're asking humans to like rip their
heads off and remove them from
situations i'm not getting mad at you i
just i remember that
i agree with you i regret bringing it up
because it's less time that i can put
you in a locker room go ahead start the
next one and your stupid idea
no i just i've always hated it from the
first time i became aware of it the idea
and we've argued about this before if he
had fumbled the ball while reaching for
the goal line and it had gone out of
bounds at the one inch line without
touching the pylon it would have been
cleveland ball at the spot of the
variety that's the field
change because it hits the pylon the end
zone's part of the field no i don't i
like it i don't get it it's a team
defending it and it's their territory
hence why you get six points when you
take the ball over it it's all their
territory no it's not the territory it's
not it's nobody's territory it's the
field to play and everybody is fighting
for the territory there's only one
there's only 10 yards that's your
territory that's only a definition to
explain what side of the ball you're on
the field you're on it's you're on the
chief side of the field the brown side
of the field you lost the ball
in their area why would they give you
the ball back where you from oh here you
go that's like the most millennial
recovery crap ever not that that is shut
up about that that's horrible don't call
me millennial when everybody has come
out that's what it is we'll be fumbled
but we want the ball back we fumbled and
we want it back give it to us right
there
but that's how it happens anywhere else
that's what it's not anywhere else it's
the end zone over the ball it's the end
zone it's not anywhere else it's not
going to get it on the 20. it's why do
you get it because just the way you get
a touch back or somebody punch the ball
in the end zone or somebody misses the
field goal then it goes out of bounds
you get the ball to touch back that's
how it works it's called the sport it's
called rules it's the way it was just
laid down can i use and not get fired i
know i can't give you the fingers no i
know
what about what about last night when
the bucks are returning with their
defense a pick six
and and the guy stepped out of bounds at
the three what if he had fumbled through
the end zone then he that's the defense
that's not the offense doesn't the
offense would have gotten the ball back
it does it doesn't matter it's still the
saints are defending that end zone from
a team scoring in there it's still the
same thing even though yes they were on
offense now the ball possession has been
changed and they're stopping them from
there you didn't give me a very good
argument counselor you lost all 12
jurors that sims won enough time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports